I first saw this film
Hitchcock some Alfred Hitchcock's
adaptation of dial M for murder which is
based on this stage played by Frederick
not I saw Hans first release and like
most people at the time I saw it in 2d
two dimensions flight because of course
the big 3d craze was 1953 all of
Hollywood's first 3d pictures you know
wanted devil was the first at House of
Wax inferno phantom of the Rue Morgue
that were all made around 53 54 but
after CinemaScope came along 3d was
dropped didn't after wear the glasses
with scope the Hitchcock's film was made
in 53 but it was released in 54 and
therefore was more widely seen in a flat
version not in 3d now 1980 the picture
was re-released in 3d and when we saw it
then it was a revelation what at the
time seemed like a really good Hitchcock
picture suddenly became I think a great
one something I went back to over and
over again even in flat version I mean
when I saw it in 3d Hitchcock it seemed
to use the 3d very expressively
and somehow the emotions deepened the
emotions within this small apartment and
Mayfair in London where the action is
mostly set I mean every chair every
table all the distances between the
people become very charged and the 3d
brings the sort of the inner world the
characters within their living space
very very very close to the audience
when I watch the picture I wind up sort
of feeling my way through the apartment
becoming familiar with it in the way
that you know I become familiar with the
spaces where I live and work of course
well I got to do Hugo in 3d with Rob
first film I showed to the crew was a 3d
copy of talent for murder in the
synchronised style in other words not
digital
and they were quite amazed I was amazed
all over again the picture was a real
learning experience always is I was like
watching it but particularly in 3d but
for example in 3d how do you film a key
going into a lock close up insert or
even better how do you how do you do the
key show the key being placed under a
piece of carpet on a stair it sounds
simple it's like insert key in carpet
you know insert key in Lock it sounds
simple but it is and watching the way
Hitchcock does it it's always a lesson
not to mention a moment in 3d which is
the only kind of outrageously exploited
to exploit it to a moment in the picture
in terms of 3d but it's electrifying and
you're about to see that too
so I really do envy you tonight watching
that and I hope you will enjoy the newly
beautifully restored version of the 3d
masterpiece by the great Alfred
Hitchcock